and this is why Kevin Jonas will always
be the most relatable Jonas brother
[Music]
Joe Jonas mocks his older brother Kevin
it was funny well at least Joe seems to
seems to know it all started because of
this moment from the Jonas Brothers
recent Tonight Show appearance
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a couple standout moments here we
gotta break down first Kevin's dance
moves
[Music]
then Kevin thinks host Jimmy Fallon's
gonna reach out for a handshake but he
ends up giving himself a high five
instead
so Joe did what all little brothers do
make fun of it on Tick Tock and this is
why Kevin Jonas will always be the most
relatable Jonas brother
[Music]
but don't worry it wasn't a true Joe
Blow to the ego cause Kevin got in on it
too and this is why Kevin Jonas will
always be the most relatable Jonas
brother
there's really nothing off limits yeah
this isn't the first time Joe's trolled
kept oh yeah last month Kevin almost
took a tumble during a performance
that's him spinning in circles before
his guitar hits the mic stand he trips
and nearly Falls
[Applause]
so what does Joe do naturally he asks
Kevin to apologize to the mic stand it's
part of the journey Joe took the joke
even further taking footage of Kevin
stumble to tick tock set to the Viral
song Dumb Ways to Die
[Music]
the connection we have as a family still
is is really unique and that connection
is keeping the Jonas Brothers music game
going despite any hijinks on social
media the band screwing up to drop their
sixth studio album simply titled the
album on May 12th what made you think of
the title of the album
well every other name was chosen already
yeah we just went on Google and we're
like wow somebody didn't use that yet
[Music]
how would you describe the next era of
Jonas Brothers music
I don't think you're ready
honestly while we brace for jb6 we'll
keep our eyes glued to their Tick Tock
accounts for more of that brotherly love
and this is why Kevin Jonas will always
be the most relatable Jonas brother
[Music]
foreign